they're staring regime of Bashar Assad
is close to controlling all of Damascus
for the first time in about five years
hundreds of rebel fighters are
evacuating the last part of Damascus
held by the opposition Seth Doane is in
Damascus with how the fight is affecting
life there Seth good morning good
morning reminders are everywhere that
Syrian President Bashar al-assad is in
control of the center of Damascus for a
regime that does not shy away from
propaganda one of its biggest victories
may be closer than ever controlling not
just the center of the city but the
outskirts - Assad Syrian army has been
bombarding the suburbs of Damascus
destroying his own city to root out the
opposition those who weren't killed were
given the chance to surrender
thousands of rebels and civilians
boarded buses near Damascus over the
weekend destined for other
opposition-held areas four hundred
thousand people are believed to have
been killed in this war it makes these
scenes from the main souk and Damascus
just about four miles from the front
line seemed surprisingly normal
residents here do have security but war
has affected them Abu Muhammad has been
selling tamarind juice out of this
elaborate contraption for nine years and
prices have skyrocketed the fighting
also affects us psychologically he
admitted that we are strong as long as
our leader Assad and strong nearby this
ice cream parlor was packed in the 90
degree heat as Syrians indulged Bashar
al-assad watched on and student while as
a spotter supports him maybe American
thinks that all the people you need
under the indices maybe or under
attack or under rockets and missiles
it's not like that at least it's not
like that here in central Damascus and
those are the scenes the regime wants to
get out stability and security where
Assad has control Norah great reporting
Seth Joan there in Damascus Syria thank
you